[Music]  it's et's social study a quick look at  what stars are posting online I think  that my mom and dad really taught me the  value of just unconditional love and  just always being there for each other  it's been ten years since the death of  Steve Irwin daughter bindi instagrammed  a touching tribute to her mom Terry and  lay father that read soulmates in this  life and every other true love lasts  always Katy Perry confirmed she's  performing at the 2017 Grammys and  continues to sport a new look the singer  posted this pic rocking a light pink  ensemble and bleached blonde hair  captioned new life who dis and Billie  lourd continues to grieve after the  death of her mom Carrie Fisher and  grandmother Debbie Reynolds the scream  queens actress posted this photo looking  at piece while enjoying nature and  captioned the pic with hashtags blase on  the outside blessed on the inside  finding the funny just to like try and  just remain yourself and be true to  yourself  [Music]